uh we're here to talk about gradient
boosting tonight
if
i can impose could anyone who's used
this before raise their hands co-workers
no cheating
awesome we got four or five people in
the audience
hopefully you all can find a business
use case for this after we're done
because i think it's a it's a really
interesting algorithm
so gradient boosting is uh is a boosted
ensemble of decision trees fitted in a
stage-wise forward fashion to minimize
the loss
which is a bunch of words that are
somewhat complex but what it really
means
is it's a sum of decision trees where
each tree corrects
the errors or attempts to correct the
errors of the previous
union of trees so in that sense it's
fundamentally a very different algorithm
than random forests because random
forests is all going out and
independently doing its own thing and
then having some voting or weighted
combination at the end
and this is not
really the same at all
so
in a practical sense
my boss always wants me to talk about
why should anyone use this or why should
anyone care so i have some experience
working on very large advertising data
sets where very large runs roughly in
the petabyte range
so even if you very very heavily sample
you're still looking at millions of rows
and thousands to tens of thousands of
columns
and what we found is that we could
achieve a significant lift over linear
models
and
what we want to do with this
is
basically take our set of cookies or
device ids or whatever it may be and
rank them for an advertising campaign
compute an expected lift to some depth
into into our ranking
and then choose that as the group of
cookies or identifiers or what have you
that we're going to advertise too
so the thing about this is that if we
can improve that ranking or improve our
lift calculations this goes directly to
the company's company's bottom line
that's either
increased
increased conversions decreased ad spend
and or happier clients or all of the
above
and the way you're graded on these sort
of things is you're graded on a return
on ad spend so all your clients are
basically giving you some budget and
they're letting you make advertising
decisions and then they're deciding
whether they're going to re-up with you
next quarter based on this quarter
perhaps this month's returns
so
you need to get it at least
approximately right
and so
as compared to linear models what
gradient boosting will allow you to do
is
in some sense somewhat automatically
build
in a greedy fashion a series of higher
order interaction terms so the example i
really like is that
generally young people in college
don't have a ton of money to spend but
if you see young people in college on an
ios user agent
that does tend to mean they have quite a
bit of money to spend for the right for
the right advertiser
and
i understand that you could probably
have a human think of that
but
the one of the things that gbm really
does for you is it gives you this sort
of greedy search
so it can augment the the human analyst
search through this giant set of feature
combinations that exist in your data
and
of course there's some
it's a polynomial growth so
the
you're going to be unable to
you're going to have a hard time doing
that by hand and so anytime you can find
a tool that will help the analysts do
these searches it's valuable
now one of the things that we did
discover is it's painful to get this to
run in r it's these are not fast models
to build
and particularly when you toss a lot of
data in it's relatively slow so we did
have to do some significant down
sampling
and we knew that that was bad so if
we're willing to wait we can discover
better models without down sampling but
you need something like at minimum a one
week turnaround time on these
in order to
to make new advertising decisions if for
no other reason then cookies churn
so you need to constantly be refreshing
your model to account for new cookies
and new interactions
so the other products that i've worked
on are
demographics and the thing about devon
graphics is it's very self-correlated so
younger younger people go to college
older people make more money
you're going to have trouble if your
models expect
nice independent explanatory variables
and again this is something that gbm
will be able to help you with
and it can pick up on three and four
deep feature
feature products so you know people who
visit car enthusiast forums you may
think make good advertising targets for
luxury models but they don't because a
lot of people just go and like to look
at these cars
so if you're a car person you probably
go to i don't know bmw or mercedes
websites and just look at these cars
even though you're not going to buy a
100 or 200 000 s series or what have you
but if you can find the people who visit
the car enthusiast forums and
visit certain types of review sites in
some time bound those people are
shopping and luxury car segments are a
very valuable
target category for for marketers
either because bmw wants buyers or they
want to poach each other
so in a more theoretical sense
gradient boosting is a is a
multi-purpose classification and
regression tool
and i mentioned it performs a variable
selection during the fitting process and
it's also nicely robust to highly
co-linear explanatory variables
as opposed to glm
you can do all these things in glm but
backwards forwards at least in my
experience tends to be somewhat unstable
um
so
gbm will do a interaction search to a
specified death in a greedy fashion
thank you cliff and it will capture
non-linearities in the data without hand
feature engineering so another example
is airline on-time performance gbm will
capture sort of
an unfortunate change in 2001 without
having to have an analyst sort of go in
think about the problem understand it
and hand code it
the another reason to use gbm is it'll
it'll cleanly handle missing data which
is a which is a known pain point for any
of your general linear models you're
either going to
drop those rows perform some sort of
imputation lose the columns do a number
of things but gbm handles nas and glm
won't without a bunch of pain
gbm will also sort of naturally handle
unscaled data so if you're using glm
ideally it's
it will handle completely unscaled data
though in a practical in a practical
world your matrices will have
will have issues in computations but
again if you apply l1 or l2 penalties
those are nothing like unscaled and so
if you have variables measured in sort
of different units or different order of
magnitude units l1 and l2 errors will
will be very problematic
um
gradient boosting will also handle
ordinal data so something like an
ordered factor if you know what that is
so
if you have
you know income categories 10 to 20 20
to 40 40
the 100 or etc
again recall that glm is a linear model
so the assumption is that plus one of a
dependent variable creates plus one of
the corresponding beta
effect either in your your exp in your
dependent variable or in the link
function
sorry i i think i said that wrong
plus one of the explanatory variable
will create a corresponding plus beta k
in your dependent variable
and the problem with an ordinal is what
should the distances between neighboring
or
non-neighboring levels b
glm because it's a tree based thing will
handle this in a very natural way for
you
and glm certainly has a number of tools
that you can you can use to discover
this but they require a bunch of
fiddling and gbm can just handle it
finally it's relatively insensitive to
long tail distributions and outliers and
it's also handles
differently scaled data very nicely
so on the right data set gbm
classification will outperform both glm
and random forests
and it demonstrates good performance on
various classification problems i went
trolling through the internet if you
look at the kegel forums for example
this will be one of the standard tools
that you will get told to apply first
when you go enter any of the
competitions
and there's a couple people who've been
very successful the one i like is in the
the kdd cup in 2013 three of the top
four teams used it and one of the
winning teams found that they could get
very good results with gbm alone and
nothing else
but they did point out that the main
disadvantage of um
gradient boosting is that it's slow so
they were using only 300 trees
so
here is um
so you can get some intuition about what
it's doing on the inside it's a tree
learner and then we're taking a whole
bunch of trees and and weighting them in
a very particular sense
so what you're seeing here is um
gbm after only one iteration so only one
tree and if you look on the left i built
this this function which is certainly
non-linear although if you are lucky
enough to directly observe it you could
imagine fitting it with a spline or a
polynomial
in the middle i have one pass and so
what you can see is that your
explanatory data is being cut up into
chunks and you have uh six nodes here
and when within each node you're
predicting a constant value and on the
right you can see the residuals now the
thing you should note is that because i
have a shrinkage thing my prediction is
on a different scale so it's a it's a
very slow growing sort of thing
so here you can see the same view on the
same scale
the predictions have barely moved from
from where they started
but if you fast forward from one tree to
20 trees you'll start to see it move
30 trees 100 trees it's starting to pick
up on what's going on
and around 300 trees we have a pretty
good
pretty good set of predictions the other
thing you'll notice is that you're
clicking through
the residuals are basically
basically falling to something around
zero and so what you can see from that
is these tree based algorithms are
carving your data up into into
into different nodes into different
chunks and they're essentially building
um different different predictors for
each of these chunks
and the bigger residuals get a stronger
weight
so
briefly the algorithm you're gonna
for for a classification problem for
example you're to normalize your data
all of this is building regression trees
which is the the central piece of this
algorithm and then we
we cleverly compute weights for the
outputs and wash rinse repeat and as
cliff is going to tell you this is
interesting not only because i think you
should have a sense of what a regression
tree does because it's the core of this
algorithm but because that's where the
time goes
everything else is a tiny little bit of
computation around building regression
trees
and if we could quickly walk through
what a regression tree actually is
imagine i have this bag and i have some
residuals and on the first row i have my
x's now the thing you should notice is i
can only i can only split when the x
variable changes so i have
three three opportunities to split one
to two two to three and three to four
so this is sort of a view of what a
regression tree is actually doing it's
carving it up into different pieces left
to right it's sweeping over my potential
cuts and it's it's attempting to
minimize a squared error over the
residuals
so ones on the left ones and twos three
and fours on the right one two and three
four on the right and what it's finding
at least in this case is that the
minimal air is carving out one on its
own
and everything else
to the right available for a future pass
similarly what a regression tree is
really doing here
is it's carving up
a pair of variables
into sort of
rectangles with divisions orthogonal to
the axes so there's a direct
correspondence between the tree on the
left and the division of space on the
right
and then within within each one of these
one two three and four uh units of um
space on the right it's it's building
individual models based on the
likelihood that you chose when you ran
the model
now as much as i do like gbm there's
some some serious pain points it's it's
slow to fit and it's slow to predict
this is basically unsurprising because
you're doing this sort of greedy search
over some combinatorial ex
explosion of an optimization problem
particularly if if you're willing to let
there be fifth order interactions you
have something like the power of the
number of the number of explanatory
variables you have to the fifth power
which is which is
quickly enormous
it has severe data size limitations
you're often going to have to do down
sampling and of course the fear when
you're down sampling is that you're
throwing away
data that otherwise would improve your
model
many implementations are single threaded
so
it kind of sucks to buy a very nice 32
core computer and watch one core sit
there and work and the other
31 sit and spin while you're waiting for
your model output
finally the parameter parameters are
relatively difficult to understand so
things like interaction depths like how
many sets of variables do you consider
are relatively straightforward but the
rest of them what's going to work well
for you
is going to be very data dependent and
you're probably just going to have to go
look and do some sort of brute force
search and measure
the performance of your model over this
space
of course with some ability to trade off
the amount of time versus the quality
and improvement in the model results but
this is going to make a slow job even
slower
and so as compared to ours gbm which is
one of the very popular models
h2o is willing to work with up to 65 000
factors
we have it running in-house on very
large amounts of data
over 100 gigabytes and we'd be happy for
it to work on much more
and we're seeing four
forex speeds are faster on a single node
and it does scale with the number of
nodes in your system
and that's it so i'm going to hand
things over to cliff and he's going to
talk about an implementation
okay so i'm going to um shift directions
okay so um
or you mean on the implementation side
here
i i
yeah okay so um this algorithm came from
uh trevor hastie uh in his book on
elements of statistical learning uh i
think there's a whole section in the
book on it and in particular i'll show
you the page i think earl flopped that
page up which is what we've implemented
um and so we'll get there okay so so the
the shift and direction i'm gonna go
here is i'm the systems implementer
engineering guy and not the math guy so
i'm implementing the math that people
say works well and i figure out how to
make it go fast
um
so what what really is going on here is
uh hex data is building a thing we call
h2o which is this pure java open source
stuff here's the github link you can go
download and play with the source code
and what it really is it's a platform
for doing math so in particular parallel
and distributed math and we're using it
to do a lot of in-memory analytics so uh
gbm but generalization remodeling random
force logistic regression there's a
number of things k-means um and the the
platform is drivable and from a number
of different directions including uh
rest and json which from uh the rest in
json paradigm you can get to r which
we'll demo here in a little while
rstudio i'll drive some demos from that
from excel from python from a number of
other languages so it's a very general
purpose way to get at this thing
and then the parallel distributed part
is basically
as much memory and system and cores as
you put together in a cluster
okay so what i'm going to talk about
then is some notions of doing stuff with
big data so what is the notion of how do
we talk about it then i get a
distributed tree algorithms for which
gbm is one of them and random forces
another and there are others floating
around and then we'll get into specifics
on uh gbms on h2o and and how fast and
how long and so forth and so on so the
first thing we'll talk about here is big
data
and how do i talk about big data
so
h2o internally builds a thing we call
avec so this is this java code i wrote
up here and avec is like
it's like a java array
except it has more than two billion
elements maybe as many elements as
fitting along or in your cluster and
just fast random access to get things
and to put things and there's a notion
of missing elements because a lot of the
algorithms need that and they can be
variable size have some other
interesting
features and
the the vectors
are um
we we collect them and we align them in
memory in a way that fits the notions
you have about a like an r data frame
about looking at your data so there's
some pile of these vectors all striped
through memory and they're aligned on uh
they're aligned in the jvms but they're
striped across the cluster so any
individual vector here might be bigger
than what fits on one machine but
certainly the collection of all of it is
however when we stripe it this way
we can get access to a row across at
fast access for any one jvm
for that one chunk of data but the one
jvm while he can get out the other data
it's a network traffic overhead so the
goal here is to have each jvm work on
data that's local to himself and
describe what they're doing the math
they're doing in a way that's sort of
natural and easy without thinking about
the boundaries that are breaking the
data up here because if i do that i'll
never get my algorithms written so
within these chunks of data i have
within these vectors i have i break
things up into chunks that'll show up
here in a little bit a chunk is
typically a thousand to a million
elements
and it contains my raw data
internal to a chunk i do some sort of
compression the effect of the
compression is typically my in-memory
data is
no bigger than the gzipped file on disk
and often smaller sometimes two or three
x smaller so i get a fair amount of
compression here and
despite the compression i can pull it
out in a few clock cycles generally
faster than my memory can stream it in
to the cpu so the compression's
essentially for free in that sense right
it didn't cost anything to do the
compression and i win because i get more
data
i can squeeze more data into ram
okay so within the chunks
you know a cpu is going to work on a
chunk he's going to work on all the
the data across all his uh columns
within a chunk and another cpu is going
to work on another chunk another one
another chunk and so on and so forth and
so pretty much i light up all the cpus
as i march through the data and do
something with it
so this notion of a chunk shows up
because it's my unit of parallel
execution parallel access
and then i'm not moving the data
anywhere and typically the codes move to
the data everyone runs their piece in
parallel and then they roll up results
together and that's what we're going to
get to here in a minute but it's all
about um
talking about what i'm doing within a
chunk this is the main core of the
algorithm and then there's a roll-up
phase for the data between the cpus and
then across the clusters uh rolling up
to the to the top level where it's being
driven
so to summary summarize i've got a frame
which is very similar to an r frame um
it's a collection of vectors the vectors
can be billions of elements long
they're broken up into chunks which are
big enough that i can do some sort of
efficient batch processing on a chunk
but a chunk might be a thousand to a
million elements and elements
conceptually a java double um although
it's actually any you know how it's
stored memories up to the compression
scheme if i have a column full of
booleans it will be stored in memory as
a bit set and i don't think about it as
a bit set it's just uh
happens to contain only two values and
when i say do get me the value i get
whatever the two choices are
and then i can talk about a row of all
the elements of a vec going across
and and my guarantee is that this will
be efficient
if i talk about the same row on one cpu
i can march sideways through the data at
essentially no cost
okay so within that taxonomy here i have
sort of three ways to look at the system
and and you know the the top easy level
way is to say i don't think about
distribu distribution coding at all
um and this is using rest and json
to drive whole algorithms so i can go to
the console or i can go to my r console
and um
say please load this data set from s3 or
hdfs or local disk wherever it is
and the fact that it's being loaded in
parallel across the cluster is not
something i care about or i see it's
just going to get loaded that way
striped across the cluster it's all
invisible it happens it's done then i
can say run gbm or run glm or do
whatever and we'll demo this in a little
bit and i'll get an answer back and in
that sense i'm just
cycling the system like it's a black box
for doing math and it's very useful at
that level
that's a good point okay so how many
people here um
code are interested in coding math at
some level versus using it so the coders
people who do coding for a living or
we're thinking about doing code for math
so like a third of the audience maybe
it's interesting how many people here do
math for a living and are interested in
a black box that magically runs math
faster
so i got
fewer several yeah there's some
scattered around okay that's very
interesting
i might shift talks here i i went for
the data sciency talk and i have the
systems engineering version
we can go into more detail if you want
okay so this talk
much of what comes next is going to be
how to do data parallel coding in a way
that's sort of reasonably easy to look
at and in particular it's going to be
heavy on the mapreduce but not your
grandfather's mapreduce
so
when i say mapreduce i'm talking about
nothing to do with hadoop but with the
conceptually clean notion of map and
reduce so map takes as a function from
my data to some value and reduce takes
pairs of those things whatever they are
and folds them together pair by pair and
gives me one where i used to have two
so this particular map is conflating the
types it's a little harder to see what
the choices are but it's just going to
do the obvious sum of squares and the
map is taking some value doing some
function on it and returning me
something it might be of a different
type but this map this type matches this
type and the reduction takes pairs of
these and folds them into one
and then i say do all and i've handed a
vector and this will run parallel
distributed across my cluster within no
further work
so this piece of code just gives me sums
of squares uh and in fact it will run it
at memory bandwidth speeds here i can't
actually make it run any faster it's
it's going to be
milliseconds per gigabyte kind of speeds
um
but i can get more complicated in my
inner loop so let's look at that
so i can have state in particular and in
this case the map is taking multiple
inputs however many inputs i want and
producing of this pointer and he's
updating in place in memory
so i'm showing again something fairly
simple it's the linear regression pass
one but i have something pretty
complicated in here uh that i'm
accumulating state on and it's really
into this pointer and the reduce is
taking to this and of that
and folding them together
so
a map will run over a chunk for a
thousand or million elements
in parallel with all other cpus running
their maps over all their thousand two
million elements
and reduce we'll take pairs of those
million elements and fold them together
in a logarithmic tree roll up
most of the reduces will happen within
your node but when you've done all the
work on your node they'll start going
across the cluster pair by pair of the
network until they roll the results back
to where you started from
so here it is with the chunks more
exposed
so here's my batching
where i can say for i equals 1 to the
length of a chunk so i've passed in
chunks here instead of raw values and
then i fetched my double x and y out by
calling chunk at and chunk at
and this is where my decompression
happened
so this is under the hood it's doing a
bit set vector lookup if that's what
your data is stored at and it's shift
scale add or whatever the compression
scheme of the moment is and then you do
the same map you had before and the
reduction is unchanged
so this is pretty efficient actually
and this is just doing stride one access
through memory and so is that x86 is
really good at prefetching that this
will run at memory bandwidth speeds and
saturate your cpus and do the math all
at one go
and because it's a batch thing i can do
work outside the loop if i have some
interesting loop and variant stuff to
pull out and know that that extra work
is not happening everywhere all the time
for every row it's happening once per
chunk which are already a thousand to
one or a million one reduced from the
original work so this is a pretty
efficient way to to write things if you
can contemplate your code as a map and
reduce
all right so
i have
more systems decided on the kind of
stuff you can do let me back up a slide
here and go back and we'll pull the
audience one more time so i've shown
some real basic stuff here but i can get
into more detail doing group buys and
uniques across clusters and all kinds of
cool things you can do in this paradigm
in a very straightforward way
because we're looking at gbm tonight i'm
going to turn over and head for gbm
but i can come back and talk about more
the kinds of things you can do in this
paradigm that we're going to run like
really fast across your cluster
so here's the algorithm i think you saw
this page before is this
hasty tip sherani and friedman
it's an eye chart in some ways
but most the math here is really cheap
and easy except this one fit a
regression tree where you have
millions or billions of rows
and what is the cost and time of
building a regression tree
how do we make that go fast
so what i'm really going to talk about
now is how i contemplate think about a
tree on data that's striped across the
cluster
and what i really do is i take the
the nodes of a tree the leaves of a tree
and assign every row to whichever node
on the tree it happens to land in if it
was walk down the decision tree it ended
up on some node some leaf of that tree
so i give it a number and i assign a
node to the number by making a giant set
here and i for each row i've set it to
whatever node had yet landed on
um
and this is some temporary vector i've
made so by the way
this makes me a vector that's of size
equal to the original guy so it's a
parallel temp
except because it's all full of zeros it
compresses really really really well so
it's essentially free cost me not like
almost nothing at all to make a zero
vector of a billion elements
and then i make a pass over all the rows
so when i visit a row it's at some node
i don't know which one so the nodes are
not visiting order but the rows are
visited in order and because the rows
are visited in order i'm very efficient
at touching my data and then i'm going
to do some work per row and in
particular what i do is i grab
histograms
so let's go look at what that turns into
so i have some initial tree here um and
i've started all rows at node zero and
i've got some value of my uh
my uh predictor and some values my
response variable and i'm trying to
figure out how to split this tree up so
i can make a prediction on my y based on
just x's right so make a sweep over all
the data and accumulate sums and sums of
squares and get average and variance out
okay fine using that information i'm
looking for a split decision
and one of the things i didn't say here
is i've done the the
the histogram building is built on uh
x's as they're broken out by two
different choices and i go through the
same decision that you saw with earl
where i walk down the line saying if x
is less than zero less than one less
than two less than three here's my error
and my variance as i walk through right
based on that i come up with some
decision
and i decide to encode it in the tree
the tree is just a pojo a plain old java
object so i didn't do anything special
about the tree except to find a java
object that looks like a tree and looks
like a java tree object whatever and i
give it a decision hey if you're column
x and if you're 1.5 go left else go
right and then i make another pass over
all the nodes and when i make the pass i
pick each node and apply it to this
decision and it goes left or right
and i assign a new node id to it and
then i bend it again
according to which piece it landed
so i end up with a histogram for every
node in the tree and whatever rows
landed on that histogram pile in and
they get a an average and a variance
for that particular node
and then you know looking again at this
set of
data this is my small data it's only two
right now it's two elements of the tree
even there might be a billion rows in
each set i end up with two things and i
look each one split it or not
looks pretty clear that node two doesn't
need to be split anymore it's got a good
decision variance is very low if i just
predict 1.2 i'm like spot on
whereas the other guy's pretty big
variants so maybe i decided to like chop
this guy off
but i'll keep going
with the other guys make another pass
through all my data and decide to split
it again and get a different predictor
value for the leaves on that
and so on and so on as i add layers to
the tree
so it really happens is that i need a
layer i need a pass of my data for each
layer in the tree
but every pass is fully data parallel
so as i add more data if i add more
nodes i divide the work of the data by
the nodes that i've added and i keep
dividing the work per layer
to get my speed up right so sequentially
i'm going down
but each sequential pass is as fast as i
have nodes to divide the data up amongst
okay yeah so this is what i said each
pass is a layer of the tree but i'm
building them uh one at a time here
this is a
short eye chart form of the past i'll
touch it real quick and then we'll move
on here
so i have a map call
over my data
and so i've just made a pass thing which
comes from mapreducetask he's got some
node ids he's pulling out one of the
chunks here is my data so all my columns
are my chunks array so my node id's as
temps and i'm rolling over all my rows
grabbing out the the length of the roads
there i pull a node id out for this row
and then i go ahead and make sure
there's a histogram not all chunks will
see all nodes in all trees some chunks
will all like land here or land there so
i'm lazily producing my histograms but
once i got a histogram i go ahead and do
whatever accumulate does which in this
example is going to compute
bend my predictor and then compute you
know sums and sums of squares for each
of the different pieces so i can make a
decision later and i just say do all on
my data frame and my extra temp
variables and this is running now
across the cluster and i'll show
examples which look very similar to this
straight out of the h2o code base here
if people are interested but this is
pretty dang close what the actual codes
look looks like
cliff and i started this company after
being uh finding no tools for after
starting at an r screen for more than 12
hours or 16 hours myself and trying to
build simulations that took weeks its
length
i mean all science has been now the
lowest common denominator is data
science data collection is cheap data
science is the only science left so we
want to give build great tools and make
them available
in apache v2 so you can embed it to use
it plug it into our
i mean the future looks like it'll just
be our
wrapper basically
another package that implements cool
packages in our so you guys can access
it from our and python and excel we are
not yet another big data startup trying
to be
trying to do something cool while it's
popular we're going to be around we're
going to build this math library till we
find the right math for our time i think
one of the things missing in this whole
discussion is gbm is the cutting edge
algorithm and that's why we're starting
there but what if the math that's needed
to solve our big data problems is
missing
and that's kind of where we want to
encourage the audience to be part of
this um
gbm didn't come out of the blue we asked
the audience when we were building
random forests what would they like to
see in addition trees that was four
months ago so the last three months was
building gbm and the next three months
could be the algorithm you guys want so
please be part of the overall
conversation
and it's
a product's not complete without the
community behind it so with that i'll
give it back to
cliff here
the the
tar file that comes with
okay the tar file came here
comes with h2o you download it from the
web and you get it
um
you're an install package i'll come on
this side over here
and we're going to do
people can see this in the back
sort of kind of
i think one or two font size increases
wouldn't hurt anybody
does it look
alright all right yeah that's when we go
on here so there's a couple steps to
install um find your package load the
dependent packages
so the main package pulls in some other
stuff we need
part of things we're using here is like
our curl and this is where we use the
rest and json to talk to and from a
cluster so what you saw on the
background was that we have a cluster
running up in our lab and so i was
getting a vpn connection to it so we can
show some big data being driven by r
uh to the back end
so it should be
so here's the ip address from our
back-end cluster as
forwarded to vpn should be 161 yeah
ah the port okay
yep
go
and the magic of vpn
bam
okay it's up and running
and this says we're connected to this
cluster
so this is the small data demo
oh
okay
oh right
yeah
all right now try this
no you didn't you didn't do the
anything yeah i didn't do the initial
launch
yeah
yes i am
um the
uh
one of the init steps needs the local
thing all right where's angie
we're gonna we're gonna do this for
locally for my laptop here in a second
yeah
isn't this a demo oh no no where's the
data
all right yeah you can't do it that way
you want to do this from uh
local here
yeah
now you need the local h2o
and then i guess this path
and hdfs colon something
so we have an hdfs
at our office that we test against
we can load data locally this one is
the cluster is running
um
i think it's airlines hall
the cluster is running at the office as
well as the
hadoop server
but they don't have to be co-located
although they can be
h2o does all its own internal clustering
and so
we don't require hadoop
we work fine on s3 we work fine on local
data sets
you can run a onenote h2o cluster
on your laptop
for nothing more than java jr issue.jar
and it'll come up and be ready to go in
that sense it's a
it's a very fast way to run gbm
okay
so this is coming from the cluster now
and here is the cluster it's a four node
cluster of 200 gigabyte machines
so it's actually a pretty big cluster
and i think there's going to be
ah we're pulling in the data set okay so
so r
has asked for this data set to load from
our studio and we're pulling in this is
a couple gigabytes worth of data
like 12 or something
okay
um and this will take a minute or two
and if we look there's some system load
and some cpus are busy and some memory
freeze free memory sizes will up and
down according to gc cycles and uh the
data is coming piling in and getting
spread around the cluster
it's on the vnc tab
yeah
so somebody's stuck doing i o it's
however fast hdfs will hand us
data uh
i don't know maybe you're done
you're on the wrong
oh you're done go go find what our
studio says
okay so you loaded 12 gigs
you want to uh you want to do like a
head of that
and so this went in to base to a cluster
and said give me the first six seven
rows of the airline data set so
120 million rows
run a summary and let's take a look so
summary is going to compute more
interesting stats
over the whole data set
and we can uh
oh there it is
so 120 million rows you've got first
quartile median mean max quartile
um
yeah
so okay here we have a web gui that does
json in and out or pretty prints the web
the um
pretty prints the json as html
so you can drive it this way
which is really convenient for
point-click shooting on things
and then if you hit the json button
upper right corner you'll get this all
piled out as piles of json
so it's convenient to drive it this way
and look at the json if you're making a
script that's using rest and json to
drive things but this was a um this was
120 million rows and i and we've broken
out like histograms of uh which which
column is this
oh okay this is yeah the carrier so 12
of all flights are done by american
airlines in the last 20 years and here's
delta at like 13
and uh you know whoever else
is like northwest u.s airways maybe in
northwest
so this particular data set is
the accumulation of flights last 20
years including their on-time behavior
and one of the fun things you can do
with this is uh
go do a prediction on the on-time
behavior of flights and see if you can
figure out
uh who's
who's fast and who's slow and wide
okay there's the last zillion rows
um
uh you went is is departure delayed is
on the screen there
do you want to drive it from here
uh yeah just do do all for now because
it's gonna be a lot easier
and it won't be a realistic model
okay
so the easier thing to do here so if
you're doing uh so the particular thing
about the airline data set is that they
also included with the departure delayed
or not
a bunch of information about why it was
delayed and so if you're building a
predicting a predictive model and you
have information telling you why it was
delayed then you were delayed so if
you're predicting delay you just have to
look over the next column and see that
oh i have a delay code so therefore i'm
delayed right so it makes a very
unrealistic model so the goal here is
we're going to look at predicting a
model where we're uh predicting on-time
behavior based on things that are not
available to 24 hours in advance
right so so don't don't get to cheat and
look for the delay code but try and
figure out why you were delayed or not
so sri stepping through the um
the the different delay codes here
diverted cancelled canceled codes
you can have taxi that's probably in
there maybe probably okay sure
i don't know i don't think it makes that
one makes a difference
uh
oops
she's the wrong keyboard it's a mac guy
on a windows box
as opposed to the windows guy on the mac
box
i think yes more crs times
the yeah
i think that's it
and scroll down
yeah you're good
okay so number of trees you want to
build
the max depth of the trees
minimum observations on the leaf
the amount of bending points you're
going to split at the learn rate which
is pretty high here
compared to what people do but we're
trying to get a demo on in some length
of time so
it flips to this mode and then and then
it starts lighting up tree uh cores so
you want to flip to the vnc session here
for a second here okay so yeah so here i
am running data parallel across uh 12
gigs of data 120 million rows of data
and in the little like
that's that's stopping to roll up the
data and and declare tree split and go
to the next one and every five or six of
these maybe it's like eight or nine of
these you get another tree
level done there's some number of these
passes here to make a tree i don't have
the right count of them but it's it's
going to be building trees as we go here
and we've got some trees built
um and because the shrinkage was there
as point one you can imagine that means
that the predictive quality of a tree is
reduced by ninety percent
so each tree only moves the bar just a
little bit away from the median to try
and get a better better prediction and
the reason for that shrink is just to
avoid overfitting but it also means you
a lot a lot of trees to get a reasonable
fit so in the beginning we pile on trees
the fit's pretty bad and we're slowly
creeping in on it and of course the
refresh is like wiping the screen down
and you can't shrink the font but you
can see it's still pounding away here
and lighting up all the cores i guess
these are 32-way machines
yeah it's four times 32 is a 128 cores
like going to town
these are not expensive these are linux
intel boxes
and
typically we find our customers use one
of those boxes
but it usually lights up one core
i think that's the the big pieces of the
demo why don't i uh take questions from
people for a while here
people too excited about the perf bar
going up and down
12 gigs on disk
uh in ram uh maybe you can open another
tab show the data in ram
so essentially all the airline data
and basically
um
yeah i i don't have a local jvm running
but i test and play with r studio
uh just running my
h2o on my laptop
yeah random forest is designed to be
paralyzed and we paralyzed it in the
obvious way so you just run the trees in
parallel you build the trees in parallel
they're all independent
um
i have not because gbm is too new
more accuracy and slower
yeah rf rf like tops out at some count
of trees and adding more trees doesn't
seem to help it has some very neat
tricks but the thing that any boosting
algorithm is going to get you is it
weights where you're wrong
yeah and rf is fundamentally going to be
unable to do that but that costs you
and made us build the exact textbook
algorithm that cliff has for you guys um
and and i mean finally got on stage and
till it was actually the page number 370
387 on els
third edition book
he was not um satisfied and so it was
done and and approved so in that sense
of it major kudos to the team that's not
here as well but it's our advisors who
in stanford have done a terrific job but
with that i wanna i think we're running
short of time i wanna i'm gonna look up
yep
and thank you